before the lockdown in France Abdul or
azouz worked on three building sites in
the Paris region an electrician with his
own business he was in demand but since
the French government ordered people to
stay home to stem the spread of the
coronavirus he's had to stop work now
he's worried about the future the longer
it takes to return to work the harder it
will be because we'll need to restart
the building sites the work the
materials will the suppliers be
available will they have the material
needed in construction you're not paid
for 60 days so even if we started again
in May we'd not be paid until July and
we have bills to pay
Abdul laws wife Salima is also concerned
she's had to close her fashion shop in
central Paris and says even before the
lockdown her clients began to stay away
all of yourself up until the coronavirus
has had a huge impact on the shop my
clients were very scared and didn't come
so our income plummeted our regular
clients disappeared and the tourists so
economically it's a huge impact and I'm
scared of the future on the cities near
empty roads some taxi drivers continue
to work but passengers are rare in a
ten-hour shift I've only had five
passengers it covers my costs but I'm
earning nearly nothing
in fact I'm losing money but what can I
do as people stay home across France
shopping streets are quiet and
businesses closed people have lost trade
jobs income and certainty about their
future the French government says that
because of the coronavirus crisis the
country faces a recession but it will
try and support businesses and companies
with a range of measures including
interest-free loans and special bonuses
well I put me off walkathons for the
first time since the period after the
Second World War we have launched a
system of temporary unemployment benefit
to avoid mass job losses like most
people in France
Salima is getting used to confinement
but as the week's pass she wonders when
it will end and whether the financial
support being offered by the government
will be enough to revive a business
she's
voted herself to for nearly two decades
Natasha butler al jazeera angoulême
France